Now that you've learned a little bit about ALDH2,
let's see if we can put this information together with
some of the concepts about ancestry and inheritance, that have
shown up in previous lessons. Meet Dave, a fictional character
with an East Asian background. This is a pedigree
of Dave and his family For the trait of Alcohol
Flush Reaction. Now, you can see in this pedigree, Dave
has an affected mother, uncle, maternal grandparents, lots of extended
family that are affected. Now, for this
pedigree, the a allele for ALDH2 is dominant,
and that's what leads to the alcohol flush
reaction. The G allele, is recessive where we
don't see alcohol flush. Now a dominant
loss of function allele, means that, heterozygous individuals
will actually be affected. But the homozygous phenotype,
is even more severe. In fact, its so
severe that some individuals avoid drinking altogether
because they feel so sick. So if
Dave's mother is homozygous for the A allele. Then how may of her children will
exhibit at least some alcohol flush reaction? There are three children total.
Do you think it would be none of the children? 1, 2, 3, or all of the children?